[Music]
miss sweat Knicks allegations made by
mr. avenatti about you true those are
not true
never met her don't know who she is
there's a letter released within two
hours of that breaking yesterday from
annex 60 people who knew me in high
school men and women who said it was
their words nonsense totally you know
the whole thing that totally ridiculous
none of these allegations are true
correct well the Senate Judiciary
Committee has referred creepy porn
lawyer and one of his clients Julie
sweat Nick whose name is heard to the
FBI for alleged conspiracy to mislead
Congress during Brett Kavanaugh Supreme
Court confirmation hearings creepy porn
lawyer and his client claimed without
evidence that Kavanaugh was involved in
a very long series of gang rapes ten
perhaps that happened decades ago in
suburban Maryland a short time ago Cpl
spoke about the potential criminal
investigation into him here it is we
welcome the investigation requested by
Senator Grassley who obviously has no
idea what he's just done what he has
effectively done is he has now opened up
a Pandora's box
and my client and I are very much
looking forward to a full and complete
investigation into my clients
allegations creepy but undeniably brash
but unfortunately for him that is not
the only bad news he received today Cpl
also blew up his presidential campaign
completely by suggesting in an interview
with Time magazine that Democrats should
nominate a white man for president in
2020 that's obviously not allowed in
today's Democratic Party mr. porn lawyer
previously was seen as a frontrunner for
the Democratic nomination two years from
now
Senator John Kennedy serves on the
Senate Judiciary Committee and he joins
us thank you very much for coming on so
if you would mind explaining to us what
this criminal referral is about on what
basis you made it there are there very
serious allegations the committee
is alleging that mr. avenatti and miss
wet Nick violated Title 18 in the United
States code basically conspiracy making
a false statement obstruction of a
Senate committee basically the basis of
the allegation is that Miss sweat Nick
and mr. Ivan Adi said that Miss Witt
Nick had personal knowledge the judge
Kavanagh spiked punch with drugs and
alcohol the judge Cavanaugh now justice
Kavanaugh fondled women and the Justice
Kavanagh raped women and Miss wet Nick
said she had personal knowledge of that
then when she gave interviews to the
news media she recanted most of that
testimony the Judiciary Committee
interviewed Ken witnesses trying to
corroborate mr. sweat Nick's allegations
none of them could quite the contrary I
don't know whether miss sweating it was
just a pawn or not the FBI will find out
I don't know mr. avenatti based on my
relationship with him through the
committee just on what I've observed he
has he clearly has a casual relationship
with the truth and it appears to me that
he will do the right thing but only when
constantly supervised and cornered like
a rat so what you're saying if I'm
interpreting this correctly is that
there's no evidence that these ten gang
rapes took place at which Julie's
witness says she was president not
because she none none it's been looked
into but she swore that under oath so
this is going to be the one case in my
memory where someone actually gets
punished for lying to a congressional
committee under oath well and this is
serious because we want a people who are
victims of sexual violence to come
forward but if someone comes forward and
lies about it that undermines the
legitimacy of the allegations that are
valid and at one point when it was clear
that there were no corroborating
witnesses mr. Alvin
alleged that he had a witness and would
present a sworn statement but he would
not tell us the name of the witness yeah
and I will tell you it was a turning
point in the hearing I think that's
right
I think that even if you ask the
Democrats when mr. Ivanov I enter the
picture it was clear we were getting
into the foothills of the preposterous
I live there so I didn't even notice us
senator thank you the foothills of the
preposterous great to see you tonight
Thank You senator thank you